he was collaborating with bbc to look at
the lives of
people within the west indian community
and
immediately i wanted to be a part of it
because you know my culture as a
guyanese
woman i i really relate to the caribbean
and
i was just so interested in how that was
going to be made and
i remember just really telling my agent
at the time
um icky um still my agent of course and
i was just like hey can you please
search for this for me and find out you
know what's going on i was
i was willing to take you know i was
willing to play like a tree
[Laughter]
mcqueen like this is top level um jody i
want to start with you
after series two of killing eve
what were you excited to learn about
villanelle in series three
oh what was i excited about
i think for me what becomes
more important as this show continues is
to
to move the character forward and
you know because i think there's a
tendency uh to
want to keep the things that everybody
loves and has been a huge success and
and repeat them because they're working
um
but you know the more you do that the
kind of more predictable it comes in the
more mundane so
for me this idea of exploring her
background
not to necessarily um
give sympathy you know provoke sympathy
towards her but just to try and
understand her a little bit better was
was really exciting to me i like it when
they put
her in a in a situation she's never been
in before
and that situation was very unfamiliar
so
um yeah that was that was exciting and
then having played the role for so long
do you feel a bit more empowered now to
collaborate with the writers from the
early stage of production
because you know you almost know better
than anyone
definitely i mean i i think that's what
i'm most grateful for this
this show and this production for is
like they've really enabled me to find
my voice in that way
by you know inviting me into that space
and sitting at a table with the writers
and
and explaining to them what i don't
think is necessarily working or what i
really like
and being able to throw my ideas about
in that space and realize that they're
not all bad
you know like sometimes i kind of know
what i'm talking about
and sometimes i don't but that's okay
like it's a safe space so
i definitely you know i i have
definitely picked that up and and
i've definitely taken that on you know
to future
projects for sure and haley
once you'd accepted the role of jolene
in adult material which elements of the
character and the show
you're like really really keen to start
researching and where on earth did you
begin
um
well we began there were there were a
number of different
elements when it came to research or
prep there was
the research that we did myself
um sienna kelly dawn who directed it
lucy the writer we
we did a kind of collaborative research
into the world of
porn um we
were able to work with an advisor um a
lady called rebecca moore who'd
been in the industry for a long time she
was amazing she
did some workshops with myself and
sienna and
everything from kind of body language to
telling us
various different stories or the sort of
logistics of how things work
we visited a pawn set
one saturday morning um we went along
and we spoke to the
the men that worked there and the the
performers
um so there was that side of it and then
which i kind of got stuck into
particularly with rebecca because i was
very aware of
people watching it who work in that
industry and it not being inaccurate i
mean lucy had written an accurate
uh portrayal but to be able to transfer
that in the performance was very
important
um and then just separate to that i did
my own
prep that i would do on any job which is
backstory and
history and where have they been and um
just going back into lucy's scripts over
and over and over and over again because
they were so complex
and um and layered and just pulling out
as much
information as i could to to feed
what i was trying to create with jody
what
what did you uncover that maybe
surprised you the most
that you maybe weren't expecting in the
research process
specifically about the industry not even
the industry but about the role
just about the project in general
because presumably you know you go into
a project with preconceptions and then
you know through your research something
comes out
yeah well i think in in research and in
prep
the the main thing that i came to
understand was
just how um
complex the system is when it comes to
the porn industry
and how it has been big business in the
same way that um
anything on the internet is be a
google or youtube or anything else um
the sort of layers to that were quite
mind-blowing um
and that led me to then be able to
understand
because she's an expert jolene's an
expert within her field
yeah and that allowed me to then play
that with confidence
because i was able to i knew that i knew
what i was talking about because we'd
done that research
that makes sense um leticia
speaking of confidence you know your
confidence as althea is just
mind-blowing tell us about how you
became to be involved in small acts
what a role bless you bless yuriana
um i literally
um i saw this in 2015 i saw
a just a imdb article you know like when
they announce a new show that's about to
come on board
and so that steve was collaborating with
bbc to
look at the lives of people within the
west indian community and
immediately i wanted to be a part of it
because you know my culture as a
guyanese
woman i i really relate to the caribbean
and
i was just so interested in how that was
going to be made and
i remember just really telling my agent
at the time
um icky um still my agent of course and
i was just like hey can you please
search for this for me and find out you
know what's going on i was
i was willing to take you know i was
willing to play like a tree i
mcqueen like this is top level and
and you know she went to work her
herself and femi went to work and they
got the
cast and director to come and watch one
of my plays at the time that i was doing
at the gate
and it just started to just continue
from there and i think the way that
you know god would have it is just like
it all just aligned and i finished
um promoting a film and i went to
trinidad and tobago
and i literally landed in tobago and i
got this email saying that
steve wanted me to meet him about this
role about this
beautiful woman called althea jones
laquante who
was born in trinidad and i just thought
that all the stars were like just
aligning and it was beautiful
and and then yeah i just met with steve
you know and i really was
ready to audition and really you know
put the work in and
prove myself in a sense and he was like
hey man like
i've been watching your work and i
really respect you and i would love you
to come on board and
that's a big thing for us you know we we
work really hard in this industry so to
have someone just say
come on board is it's um it's it's just
a beautiful honor so
i just just dived into it right away but
that's kind of like the back
story i basically chased the parts in
2015.
good for you yes that's good thank you
thank you yeah just be brave and put
your hands up a bit like hey i'm
interested you know i want it
yeah yeah yeah so then
it must have been incredibly gratifying
when you were on set
with steve mcqueen what did you learn
from him that you want to take forward
to your next roles
i learned so much i learned um
what i learned from him is that you're
not too
you're not too um big in
in a sense of where your position and
your career is
to just see yourself as an artist and be
appreciated at
as such and i learned that from him
doing that to us
and i learned that no matter how no
matter where this career
can take you and no matter the heights
that you can reach
it's it's always okay to literally reach
down to someone's level and say hey i
see you
and i appreciate you and he taught me so
much and he taught me
about integrity and he taught me about
trust
because sometimes you know how it is
hayley uh
and jody you know sometimes you go on
set and you're like i don't know why i'm
saying this
and i don't know if i'm doing the right
thing i think you're a bit crazy and i
had a couple
of moments of steve he was like are you
sure after you would say this and he's
like
trust me and i'm like i know that you're
like uh
you know you're an amazing artist but i
struggled to trust and he really taught
me about that he really taught me that
when someone really cares and someone
spent years
dissecting you know a world and
characters and stories and
just really just putting things together
for like five years like you could
really trust them so he just
he just empowered me as an artist and i
would forever be grateful to him for
[Music]
that
[Music]
you